let me ask you this yeah can the
republicans keep donald trump shut up
long enough to win the midterms like
they need to win
yes can they keep him noddled up
are you saying to win the midterms no
they're going to win the midterms yeah
the greatly thing that's going to rally
the left to come back out is orange man
everything that's happened is orange man
bad of course everything over the last
six years that's happened in this the
only reason joe biden is the president
is because the orange man
let me let me read that since you're
saying that because
this this takes it to uh a story that
came out with trump and mcconnell right
let's go into that story because it's
appropriate with what you just said 52
percent of republicans disapprove of
mitch mcconnell
as trump ramps up his pressure campaign
to topple people this is an insider
story a new gallup poll found that 52
republicans disapprove the job of mitch
mcconnell was doing as senate majority
leader as former president donald trump
continued to call for the kentucky
republican ouster meanwhile 46 percent
of republicans say they approved of
mcconnell with this small approval
rating in comparison to 71 percent
approval rating by the same group for
his counterpart in the other chamber
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
frequently referred mcconnell as the old
crow trump has criticized the kentucky
republican for not sufficiently
indulging his claim of a stolen 2020
election for helping to pass a
bipartisan infrastructure bill and for
cutting deals with democrats to raise
the debt ceiling he continues
to say you're asking the question is
he's going to stay out of it or not
trump says he'll endorse alaskan
governor mike dunlovey for reelection as
long as don libby doesn't back gop
senator lisa murkowski's re-election
campaign former president trump's
praised the the the uh president the
governor don levy that's running
complete and total endorsement this
endorsement is subject to his
non-endorsement
of senator lisa murkowski who has been
very bad for alaska including losing
anwar perhaps the most important
drilling site in the world and much else
uh murkowski was one of the seven gop
senators who voted to convict
trump in his february impeachment trial
should donald be failed to meet the
conditions trump endorsement would be
null and void and of no further force or
effect the former president said so what
what does this mean
uh
story came out yesterday saying if trump
lindsey graham said if trump wants to be
the nominee he can just say today and
he's a nominee lindsey graham quoted
yesterday's saying if trump wants to
just come out and say he's going to be
the nominee he's already nobody's
shocked that to use gerard's term
lindsey graham is gargling on uh
trump's yeah but but orange man i don't
know i don't think that was gargling i
think he's making a clear point but the
point is listen you guys are infatuated
with this gargling stuff i don't know
what's going on with you guys we just
want our breath to smoke
what are you doing for new year's eve go
have some fun for new year's eve
soho house is a membership and it's
expensive i know if you know that or not
i wanted to kind of bring that up uh but
here's the point
he has so much influence today that he's
poking everywhere he's a king maker he's
he but he is a king maker but at the
same time he's not sitting sitting on
the sidelines so here's a question
here's a question
say
republicans say they want to replace
mcconnell who's the
who's who's another person that could be
someone that could give a fight for his
money to be that because this is about
to flip here in a minute
rand paul or ted cruz ted cruz
rand paul cruz they're two of the most
hated guys no do not put rand paul on
ted cruz hate ability scale well no wait
a minute there's mccoy and ted cruz on
like the least liked people in the world
i put randy and then rand paul what i
mean i said by the left rand paul are
you kidding me have you seen what he's
done to fouchy's literally trying to
kill him
twice think people hate rand paul as
much as ted no no i'm saying the left
shout out i agree i'm saying they still
don't hate rand paul as much as ted cruz
uh yeah ted cruz is one of the least
never listened to any of the hearings
yes i have and with that nobody likes
ted cruz ted crew's parents don't like
to this is but this is exactly what his
face doesn't like
this is exactly you know who hates ted
cruz as beta or caves ted cruz yeah the
uh trump called his wife ugly and
disgusting and he's like you got my vote
trump i mean nobody likes ted cruz yeah
that was uh before he had the beard now
he's now he's tough ted yeah the uh in
cancun
the uh look this is exactly what i just
said aoc is doing this is bad for
american politics the polarization
working towards the fringes it used to
be you had to win the center to win now
it's working towards the fringes is
where the money and the volunteers are
and it's it's again we're just in this
constant cycle of this pendulum this
this galilean dialectic of getting
further and further and further away to
the edge somebody said jim jordan by the
way what do you think about jim jordan
trey gowdy by the way mitch mcconnell
trey gowdy bringing back trey mitch
mcconnell's horrible mcconnell mitch
mcconnell is awful mitch mcconnell is in
the dick cheney george bush he's a
globalist he is part of this again my
issue with the democratic party this
modern this modern incarnation the
democratic party we talked about this
with matt zeller is they don't give a
[ __ ] about the american citizen
they are all about their international
buddies they are they are representing
the international community they are
impr they are are representing global
interests not us
that's my issue with them
and that's my issue with mitch mcconnell
as well mitch mcconnell doesn't give a
[ __ ] about kentucky
mitch mcconnell cares about his standing
on the worldwide stage
and the more politicians that we have
that we elect that represent global
interests instead of their constituency
the worse this is going to get so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]